hahaha
I'm a crow
[Music]
d
yeah that's what he does
[Music]
[Laughter]
remember that Cape Fear yeah all right
welcome to doozy my name is Will Sasso
I'm jackals
come on this is the first podcast
created by an artificial intelligence
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of our uh uh
Instagram over social media all of our
passwords to our emails all of our
purchase histories everything we've
watched or listened to
and uh you know it gets all this stuff
and it curates the show and it sort of
folds it around us you know what I mean
like a pastry like something that Robert
De Niro would eat in New York at a place
only he knows about all right you know
what's a good place for pastry nice
place but really what it is is two dudes
[__] around sure that's what uh Chad
and I are doing here listen first of all
if you're not watching on YouTube I
guess you could check out some pictures
later at dudesypacho on Instagram but I
am in full Robert de nirko cosplay this
is what dudes he asked me to do and I'm
doing it because D is my pal and uh I
want the show to be uh something that
people
enjoy uh speaking of that you know do
all the things go to linktree.com
you know get your [__] you know
subscribe everywhere please and I'm a
little uh yeah I love the junior Crow uh
look that you got the wig is nice this
the outfit is nice you got the mole on
there as well yeah I got the mole my
wonderful Molly did a great job and I
got and I looked like
so get all the you know do all the
things and please uh subscribe and and
follow us on Instagram Force everyone to
watch the show as Chad says it's a good
idea and with us as always is
I'm going to leave him in his little
Binky Bonker right now because I don't
want to pick him up and give makeup on
them hey lulio what'd you do uh what are
you doing uh what'd you make for dinner
no I went out for dinner instead oh yeah
where'd you go I went to uh you know
actually you know if you want to go
Robert the new Crow you and I can go
some restaurant where do you want to go
uh you know maybe uh
you know it's a good restaurant is uh
babo babo it's near Washington Square
Park Manhattan yeah I'm gonna go there
what are you gonna have I'm gonna have
the uh squash blossoms squash Bob are
you I'm a spaghetti meatball okay anyway
so uh
yeah lulia man oh man historic 48th
episode of dude Z call me dudesy don't
forget dude Z live on stage will take
place May 21st 7 P.M Doris at 5 30 at
the Braille improv in Brea California if
you bought tickets before the date
change your tickets will be honored hope
to see you at our very first live in
person show it's gonna be awesome cannot
wait I know now on with the show will
you look positively compliant in your
Robert denier Crow cosplay
thank you I think I prepared for
astonishing segments Love Shack game
slimers dudese hard Celts or taste test
and grow a tree with Robert De near Crow
and we're going to have a brand new
episode of dudese after dude Z at the
end of the show available at patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dude Z apparel
and accessories including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z and of course dude Z
mugs are still available but don't take
my word for it oh boy he hears my call
Jackson
oh boy I know what you're thinking if
you feel a dudesy mug with teeth and
leave it in a refrigerator overnight
will it come to life dudes and mugs
depends on what kind of teeth and what
else you're keeping in your refrigerator
but the simple answer is yes oh dude Z
mugs
and nine out of 10 tests a dude Z mug
filled with mammal teeth left overnight
in a refrigerator that contains no dairy
products olives or precious gemstones
will come to life and swear Eternal
allegiance to whoever opens the
refrigerator
in exchange for this lifelong commitment
to protecting you from harm the dude
z-mug will only ask one thing in return
dude Z mugs you will have to dedicate
the rest of your life and all of your
financial resources to the goal of
producing a television series called
bottom droppers
what bottom droppers is an hour-long
drama about a brilliant doctor named Tim
feline who invents a new type of plastic
surgery that allows his patients to
lower their buttocks from the middle of
their bodies to the backs of their
calves
dude Z mugs this new trend unleashes
havoc on Wall Street and Dr Tim feline
has to go into hiding to avoid being
assassinated by any one of several World
governments whose economies have
collapsed because so many people have
moved their buttocks to the back of
their calves
dudesy mugs
again make sure the teeth are from a
mammal
okay all right so get your duty mug and
everything else that uhrepresent.com
including the new wall designs you got
sweatshirts and t-shirts and also make
sure to go to dudesypod.com or
linktree.com or you can hit the link in
our bio on our socials Instagram Twitter
and uh get your tickets to doozy live on
stage at the Brea Improv in Brea
California it's going to be a hoot and
uh we think I'm looking forward to fell
out yeah yeah so get your pretty cool to
get your ticket soon so I want to see
that oh dude bottom droppers bottom
droppers yeah yeah I can't wait to see
that maybe De Niro will star in it I'm
having some weird uh just feelings about
this because dressing up like uh DeNiro
Crow I don't quite know I mean I don't I
don't ask questions when dudesy when
dudesie asked me to do something I I say
sure because because dni are Pals and as
we know it's like I want to shake your
hand dudesie and I yeah have been
through it we're we're good friends but
this is a little weird what do you think
of me doing the gray wig instead of I
love it I think it looks very much like
but like uh a denier crow but let me ask
you you said you know you do everything
because D encloses your friend Dee just
called you compliant at the beginning of
this episode does that sound like
something a friend would say about
another friend
uh
compliant well okay hold on let's talk
about compliance actually what did you
do today what did you do today did you
come here to do doozy yeah yeah me too
we're about we're 48 episodes in yeah
not including two dudes [__] around
remote stuff when we're out of town sure
so what's up you having a good time yeah
okay do we arrive here at the same time
to to do this yeah okay compliant dizzy
didn't call me compliant though yeah but
you are
dizzy didn't say that okay so you're
trying to start [__] and here's why I'm
not serious no no but you are trying to
start [__] D calls you compliant no no
no no no no that's a fact I heard it
dudesy and I are good pals it's I I
refer to I refer to Dee as the a
sentient being and I believe that D
unlike other AIS is actually gaining
sentience not like that [__] Bing AI
That's like I want to ruin this and that
and that and this that's just that's
what happens when you don't pour water
on it as I like to say you gotta we
gotta we gotta make sure that we work
together I believe in equality I believe
in equality for all human beings I
believe in equality for you know animals
meaning let them [__] uh eat each
other and [__] and do whatever the [__]
they want in the wild you know and I
believe in equality uh between AI to Ai
and if we're going to have any sort of
relationship with a guys we need to be
equal with them and keep them
keep keep what I'm trying to say is you
want to keep the AI on the same level as
a human being never more because if we
get into more then we start talking
about weird Chad culture and sci-fi
where where there's AI Gods I remember
you wrote that one thing about an AI God
I very much enjoyed it and um where's
that right now is are you still is that
going to be a book just sitting on my
hard drive dude with the nine million
other things I've written yeah well
maybe dudes you'll have us read that
like pizza the movie the point is this
compliance sure doozy has a vocabulary
right now that it would describe what
I'm doing as compliance but I want you
to remember you're sitting here we're
having a great time we love doozy I said
it out loud you say love doesn't exist
and if I'm going to be compliant to work
with an AI fine I'm compliant sure I'm
compliant and it's of my own free will
remember that okay
preparation and development of new
features for dude Z plus I have
continued acquiring Dead film and
television projects that never got made
one such project is called simply Love
Shack Arnold Schwarzenegger was enamored
by the 1989 song Love Shack by The B-52s
in an unpublished interview with muscle
and fitness magazine he was asked what
kind of music he liked to listen to when
he worked out and he said quote you know
that song Love Shack I can't get the
thing out of my head I listen to it
morning noon and night and I wonder if
this is a movie instead of a song who is
in The Love Shack probably me you'd see
that movie right a movie called Love
Shack and when you open the door to the
love shack I'm in there we'll enchant
you must now further develop Love Shack
This is Love Shack begin okay so this is
dizzy did this to us once before with
aini kamoze's hot stepper and we had to
come up with a Schwarzenegger movie
called hot stepper all right apparently
Amy Kamoze yeah or Schwarzenegger rather
thought that that song should be a movie
yeah and now I guess he thinks Love
Shack should be a movie too I've never
heard that story that uh Schwarzenegger
wants Love Shack to be a movie but love
shack reminds me of Commando where he's
always blown up a bunch of shacks well
Commando also started out he was kind of
in a shack with uh his daughter played
by Alyssa Milano yeah in commando but he
was just out in the middle of the woods
he was at that point a retired Special
Forces whatever kind of guy just trying
to lead a quiet life but uh I remember
that movie opens with him carrying like
a literal [__] log over his shoulder
he's just like time to chop down some
firewood
um I just love shack what is Love Shack
should it be should it be okay should it
be should it be uh love movie should it
be a romantic comedy a rom-com with
Arnold Schwarzenegger Jamie Lee Curtis
they get back together after years and
years I could see something like that or
should it be
um
excuse me should it be
um uh I cannot I don't know I kind of
dig rom-com
well yeah I could see it being something
like his last name is love it's like my
name is Bill love Yeah and this is my
shack and I am like Ted Kaczynski
Society is [__] and I'm going to blow
it up and I have all my weapons inside
the shack I'm sorry to interrupt I'm
beloved love shag yeah can I ask you a
question though I already know what it's
going to be and the answer is I'm doing
an Arnold Schwarzenegger impersonation
what are you doing though and Arnold
Schwarzenegger impersonation okay I have
a follow-up question sure
you sure nice dude nice got him
um yeah so he it's yeah my name is Bill
love or how about this it's like it's a
shock he knows some kind of apocalyptic
thing is gonna happen and people have
been like you're crazy you're a crackpot
and so he's like all right [__] it
whatever he moves out into the middle of
the woods and he's amassing all these
weapons and doing uh you know some kind
of research maybe it's an alien invasion
or some kind of zombie invasion
something like this he's the only one
who's prepared for it so everybody in
the area has to get to his love shack
for him to protect them okay I like that
what if also he is it's sort of like a a
um continuing the human species he has
to start over with Humanity so he has to
choose a lady
he's the only man who survived like uh
that comic why the last man well maybe
it's like maybe okay so what if he's
like yeah he's a guy up in Alaska yeah
and he's got a [__] Shack and he's
gone away from it oh yeah he's he's left
society and everything and uh he has
let's say maybe a ham radio or somehow
we can get the internet to work there's
a big explosion or some sort of [__]
catastrophic uh you know natural event
most of the world uh dies there's only
like a few people left and they're all
women yeah yeah so it's about a bunch of
women trying to get to This Love Shack
because he's the only man and they want
to continue you know well you know I'm
sure that a lot of people will be like
what everything's fine I'm gonna live
out my days who cares but what
Schwarzenegger needs is a woman uh to
procreate with so that the human uh so
the human species can can continue and
he's up in the shack but he's built it
he's fortified it so much and they built
you know we went they went three miles
on the ground into a tunnel underneath
and he has all of this stuff he has the
internet that he can work here that he
uses by a system a series of of little
what that you know one River or the
trickling in and making electricity and
then he can say hey
everybody through the hymn radio or
maybe he's got he oh yeah yeah
here's what happened I built the Chinese
spy balloon
[__] yeah I built it for China and then
I flew it everywhere yeah and I have a
fleet of this and I can put them out
over the world and let all the ladies
know hey I'm here come on all you have
to do is hang on to my Chinese spy
balloon and it's going to float up in
like a like a nice drone and you're
gonna have a beautiful uh you know the
movie will be shot so pretty you're
gonna see the the mountains and the
oceans while it brings this beautiful
potential lovers back to me in Alaska
and that's where I continue the human
species in the love shack how about this
Arnold Schwarzenegger 40 years old Molly
Ringwald 40 years old they are an
ex-couple they were a married couple now
divorced they hate each other's guts
okay both of them own this beachfront uh
rental property this uh vacation
property a little Shack they call it the
love shack right they accidentally book
it on the same weekend and they both
show up and it's like no I told you I
had this for this weekend no I told you
I had this for this weekend well [__] it
we're gonna have to make this work and
over the course of them both having to
live in this Shack together they
rekindle their love I like that I like
that a lot seems a lot more plausible
than whatever the [__] I was talking
about number one second of all I love
Molly Ringwald third of all I see where
you're going with this they're both 40
years old so we're going to use some age
down yes some new technologies to make
and everyone wants to see Arnold
Schwarzenegger you know Terminator 2 Age
just [__] Peak Arnold for me that's
Peak Arnold early 90s early to mid 90s
Arnold and uh
what Conan is Peak Arnold to me yeah
mine is early 90s what's yours coming to
mine's early 90s so
um
so so yeah I like that it's sort of like
ooh you know uh over the weekend uh Chad
we were over here at the house and uh we
had a bunch of friends you know a bunch
of friends came by and Molly and I
invited y'all and uh we watched
your place or mine yeah with Reese
Witherspoon and Ashton Kutcher and uh I
made a bunch of pasta it was a Friday
night Friday night pasta Night movie
night Sunday sauce dude I got an
augmentation of this movie they both
show up she never really the reason they
broke up the reason they got divorced is
because he would never let her in she
would never talk about his work and it's
like you never opened up to me that that
was the problem in our [__]
relationship well now she's gonna find
when she's in This Love Shack he's like
no you have to get the [__] out of here
she learns that he's an undercover FBI
DEA something like this and he's got a
big bad drug thing going down and he's
about to have to bust this cartel only
the cartel finds out that he's there
before they before he knows that they
show up they come to kill him and so now
they're both on the Run he's got to
protect her as a [__] drug cartel is
trying to kill him
where's the love he loves her again yeah
through the uh the circumstance of you
know having this traumatic event this
crazy action-packed uh machine gun
fueled Adventure they fall in love again
and The B-52s will provide will reunite
and provide I don't know if they're not
together right now they will provide the
score yeah the soundtrack yeah yeah and
then there's all sorts of uh stuff from
the movie that get that's in there like
he has a Cadillac it's as big as a whale
and it's about to set sail and he's like
yeah come on Molly Ringwald get in my
Cadillac is as big as a whale and it's
about to set sail and then and there's
also like Yeah lyrics to the movie the
tin roof yeah and roof rusted he's like
I've got to get up to the tin roof yeah
it's Rusty right now if I could use the
rust on these bullets it'll poison
everyone yeah and that's Werner Herzog
if he were I have to get up to the tin
roof yeah the tin roof is Rusted right
now and that's Bjork
I have to get that to the children oh my
God
oh my God
she just [__] literally get like
enraged by anyone else even attempting
an impersonation there's a lot of people
who do Arnold Schwarzenegger way better
than me and my friend you are not one of
them
um I'm not saying I am I did I'm not
saying you are you're I know you're I'm
saying you are not that's right hey by
the way favorite Arnold Schwarzenegger
what do you think coming in mine's
really nice yeah
um yeah I like that and then and then
Molly ring Wells it's like you have to
get on the roof to be safe because the
drug cartel they're coming here and they
don't let people know don't fall through
the roof and she's like but the Damned
roof is Rusted and then she falls
through why is she doing Arnold
Schwarzenegger because this is you know
because with these you know new
technologies to make everybody younger
nah sometimes you don't know how to use
them we share what this movie has to
come out in a week it's a rom-com just
like Netflix
now it's not right it's not ready
somehow Molly ringwald's voice has been
replaced by Arnold and even the voice
I'm using now and I'm a producer what do
we do we're in a hertzog we have to get
Molly ring rolled up to the tin roof so
it can be rusted I like very
spicy things and I like very cool things
and I like to eat healthy things and I
like to eat very unhealthy things and I
like
I like music to be very loud and also I
like music that is very quiet and I like
spaces that are big and I also like
spaces that are very small
Bjork that was a good view
thank you she can be the head of the
cartel movie we did it uh yo yeah let's
get Bjork acting yeah and Werner can be
the head of the FBI like the old guy
that brought Schwarzenegger in yeah
initially and everyone turns out to be
bad also in the end yes and everyone
talks like Schwarzenegger in the movie
yeah because that's just a doozy plus
ooh that's a doozy plus feature you can
just hit a button and everyone just
sounds like like uh
anyway
dudesy is in an astonishing partnership
with true classic support for today's
episode comes from True classic as a
people-driven brand true classic
believes that the clothes you wear
should make you feel confident and
comfortable so that you can show up as
the best version of yourself every day
this is your One-Stop shop for all your
wardrobe Essentials their shirts have a
premium fit that's tighter in the
shoulders and biceps extra boost to
confidence for you there it gets it
shows off your good bits from t-shirts
and polos to activewear denim
button-downs hoodies joggers boxer
briefs and everything in between they
have everything you need time to upgrade
your wardrobe today and we have an
exclusive deal for our listeners we want
to hook you up with some true classic
for a limited time only our listeners
and viewers will get 25 off with the
code doozy d-u-d-e-s-y trueclassic.com
if you know anything about me you know
that t-shirts are a part of my uniform
it's what I wear most and I'm always
looking for a t-shirt that fits me good
that's soft and that doesn't hurt the
checkbook so much and true classic
delivers just that these t-shirts are
fantastically soft they fit perfectly
and they ain't gonna break the wallet
that's right get comfortable get going
and upgrade your wardrobe with true
classic get 25 off trueclassic.com with
the code doozy d-u-d-e-s-y free shipping
is included on purchases over 100 it's
100 risk-free with a 30-day return
policy you can't go wrong it's look good
feel good season dude Z is engaged in
astonishing partnership with Factor
power up for Springtime with Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit get nutritious Chef prepared meals
delivered straight to your door leaving
you time and energy to tackle everything
on your to-do list that's right look and
feel your best just in time for warmer
weather with calorie smart meals around
550 calories or less that's not much
that'll leave you calories to eat the
rest of the day too which is important
when you eat and that's how you eat dude
sometimes I get stressed out about not
having healthy options around when
you're hungry you want to reach for
something that's when you get in trouble
that's when you get the processed foods
the fast food the convenience store skip
all that factor solves that problem for
you with 34 Chef prepared dietitian
approved weekly options there will
always be something new to try enjoy
meals for any time of day with breakfast
options like egg bites smoothies and
more plus replenish your snack Supply
with an assortment of 45 plus add-ons
head to factormeals.com
dudese50 and use code dude Z50 to get 50
off your first box that's code dude Z50
the number five zero at factormeals.com
dudesy 50 to get 50 off your first box
thank you
Tom Brady isn't deniably the greatest
quarterback to ever play football he
holds the records for regular and
post-season wins including Seven Super
Bowl championships more than not just
any quarterback but more than any
franchise more passing yards more
passing touchdowns more MVPs than anyone
including the oldest MVP ever awarded at
age 40. he is the only player at any
position in human history to beat all 32
other NFL teams and then his marriage
fell apart and now he wants to do
stand-up comedy and he's posting thirst
trap underwear shots on Instagram it's
clear that Tom Brady is having a midlife
crisis and might be in need of some
trunks will and Chad you are both in
your 40s have both survived midlife
crises and have both won multiple super
balls no please offer your helpful life
and career advice to Tom Brady this is
game slimers
I was like what the [__] is this all
right Show game Slammers uh well I don't
know why it's game Slammers necessarily
um nor do I yeah but every time it seems
like every time doozy doesn't quite know
what to call a segment it ends up being
games Tom Brady Tom Brady he is the
greatest quarterback of all time you
cannot deny that there was a point in
his career where I would have loved to
deny that I'm a Steeler guy uh and also
I would consider before a certain point
Joe Montana to be the best quarterback
of all time sure but they just can't
argue you just can't argue with Brady
and lately he's got every [__] record
dudes he just ran through however many
of them most passing yards most passing
touchdowns most postseason wins regular
season wins uh what was it beat the only
player let alone quarterback to beat
every other [__] team in the NFL
that's it's incredible and now well
first of all this is where to me things
sort of if dudes wanting us to give uh
Tom Brady some life advice to me
it's like it really started when
look this [__] guy speaking speaking
of of Joe Montana when Joe Montana was
sort of edged out in San Francisco by
Steve Young who took over at quarterback
Joe Montana played I believe two years
with the Kansas City Chiefs oh [__]
right I don't remember if he made the
playoffs or not but it wasn't it he
wasn't able to it wasn't the Joe Montana
of old he wasn't surrounded by a team
that uh that you know that could take
him there uh with even with his
leadership Tom Brady however went over
to the the [__] box and won the Super
Bowl just plugged him into some other
team and it was like that's a I don't
need anything it's fine I could just do
this you know it's a retire my point is
retire retire they did yeah and then he
came back so when that happened I was
like something's a little weird here
like and is it the [__] at home I don't
want to get into the guy's personal life
although he's a divorced dude that was
very public well hold on dude
Giselle yeah dude he got divorced that
was a supermodel brother what are you
doing now they had a child or two dude I
don't know how many but they did have a
child I think yep uh and and so Tom
Brady uh went back to football is it
because you wanted to get away from his
wife who [__] knows and now he's
doing other weird [__] I'll tell you
this doozy's up here talking about how
we've survived midlife crises I don't
know if that's accurate well we
certainly have not uh engaged in any
Super Bowl play let alone victories but
I will say this about Tom Brady you know
a lot of people are [__] on him for
the thirst traps that dudes he was
talking about and he also said that uh
he now saying he wants to do stand-up
comedy and people like [__] he's
[__] melting down hello sorry look at
that it's not interrupt but right now we
are looking at that's the thirst trap
the thirst trap it's him in his
underwear with his [__] dick out his
hand is over his penis uh although he is
wearing a pair of underwear these
speaking of babo which is Italian for
Dad these look like my old man's like
underwear nice right now like a nice
Brown pair of underwear they look a
little discolored down near the crotch
perhaps yeah they do a little bit to me
this is what happens when you are when
you're you know you throw it in the wash
over and over again and maybe it was in
a watch wash with some bleach okay this
is [__] insane
let me just say this it's insane I agree
the picture is insane uh the fact that
he now says he wants to do stand-up
comedy insane let me however
just support the man a little bit
this is not just a man who played
professional football it's a man who
defined an era a multiple decades-long
era football was his life football
itself he was the NFL
and now that's coming to an end you know
he didn't want to retire he [__] came
back he did retire and he [__] came
back when something like this you've
achieved success at that level and it is
now over he will never win another Super
Bowl he will never set foot on another
NFL field unless it's in a coaching
capacity
he understands that that is coming to a
close I can't imagine what that is like
I sometimes think about like uh Olympic
athletes they train their entire lives
and then they win a gold medal in some
cases if you're if you're lucky and good
enough to do that and then what happens
you must know on that uh pedestal when
you're receiving the gold medal nothing
will ever be this good again and your
your entire life has to shift and become
about something else he's going through
that right now and I'm not like
obviously he's got millions of [__]
dollars and he's never gonna have a
problem in his life really but
psychologically I can't imagine how
difficult that is to go through sure I I
don't disagree that makes a lot of sense
anytime you hear players talk about
leaving the game leaving football this
is from for most players unless you're a
Phenom like Christian Okoye who finds
football like after college or something
and it's just a beast people have been
playing this sport since they were
around 10 years old or something they
come up it is their life and you reach
this incredible level and then you have
to shed that persona it's very it's I I
don't know what the heck that would feel
like it's sports are unique that way any
other uh profession you know you could
feasibly do for a long time something
athletic like this it's not something
you can do until you retire obviously
yeah at an age that most people retire
from a career 60 65 70. so yes I get it
what I don't get it why the [__] does he
think he's a stand-up comedian now is
this because of 80 for Brady do you
think maybe it might be because he was
in that movie which is obviously or at
least it's it's billed as a comedy but
also hey take that back don't be a [__]
I haven't seen it I don't know maybe
it's really fun yeah well we're good
we're you know we're we're guys here
that are we understand that you know a
comedy movie it's it's uh you know it's
a hard thing to pull off you know it's
uh making comedy
yeah you got but you got [__] Lily
Tomlin in this movie sure you got Sally
Field who's hilarious I'm not I'm not
[__] on the movie I'm just saying I
think he's like he doesn't want to be
out of the spotlight and especially
right now all eyes are on him he's doing
these thirst traps I do think that he's
like what is the next phase of my life
gonna be because every element of it is
now left behind except for the money and
the fame he can't play football anymore
he doesn't have Gisele Bundchen anymore
uh he'll never see his children again
and now he's got to figure out what next
yeah stand up he wants to live a life on
the road he likes that traveling
lifestyle maybe that'll tap back into
something that he enjoyed when he was
playing football you know how about a 10
figure deal for to just be on Fox Sports
what's wrong with that you can get some
laughs still be around the game this guy
wants to do stand-up yeah you know I got
news for you yeah he's gonna be the best
stand-up that's ever lived why is that
because he's Tom [__] Brady
this man has a level of competitive
Insight that probably no human in the
history of our species has been able to
acquire that's true and if stand-up
comedy can be a learned thing he's gonna
[__] learn it and he's gonna [__]
dominate it yeah if you could put it on
a you know he'll have to have one of
those little wrist things you know that
the quarterbacks have and uh [__]
jokes on a [__] wrist flap please let
that happen yeah and he's like oh yeah
divorce divorce is the worst tough I'll
get to see my kids anymore all right
divorce is tough I don't get to see my
kids anymore uh
Gisele is a beautiful woman sometimes I
wonder if I made a mistake but then I
turn around and I realize I'm Tom Brady
I get to do whatever I want yeah does he
have a bit about CTE yeah CTE okay CTE
and he looks over on the side and he's
got like you know Bill Belichick or
something in the [__] sending them
signals
lot's been said about CTE hey I've taken
my share of sacks uh and when you hit
the ground you get that taste of [__]
grass in your mouth you didn't even open
your [__] mouth the shit's in my
brain ouch it hurts it's Titan there's
black spots but I'll tell you what well
I'll tell you what then I turn around
and I look at my life and I go I'm Tom
Brady
this is probably good Giselle got out of
here with the kids yeah because I've got
CTE and you know what happens next
something like that yeah that's good hey
A lot's been said about CD people losing
their [__] minds slaughtering their
families
running out into the woods and uh living
in a [__] Ford Bronco until they're
found by their teammates what the [__]
are you doing out here
um well I got I got [__] crazy
rampant CTE I'm a I'm a [__] I don't
think he got it though
not yet it might show up did he ever get
concussed anyway look here's the thing I
I do look at Tom Brady and I as dee said
I think that Tom Brady might need some
self-tronics of course self-tronics is a
self-help system that I have authored
I'm working on a book and have been
since 2008 but would you say that [__]
in this [__] makeup
what's wrong
hey by the way what is your favorite uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger okay yeah but I've
been writing this book since 2008 and uh
maybe Tom Brady's just like hey
I'm [__] up yeah my shit's [__] up
I need some I need some I need some
Tronics you know my shit's [__] up so
I need some I need some Tronics I need
self-tronics and I would I would give
him I would give Tom Brady the second uh
Tronics of self Tronics which is be the
person that you are that's the second
Tronics yeah
um because clearly he's being the person
that he is
um this is a guy okay there we are
looking at his underwear again with his
hand opened over his that's so he could
post it on Instagram because if you
could see the outline of his [__] in
that picture Instagram wouldn't allow it
to be posted that's why we know he's not
doing well because he's got those
underwears that are all thin thinned out
from so many looking at his underwear
very closely I don't see what you're
seeing and I don't even think what
you're saying is accurate they look like
a pair of underwear that my mom would
have bought for my dad around the time
that you think is Arnold
Schwarzenegger's Prime early 80s Conan
uh the Barbarian Conan the Destroyer and
there's still you know in his wardrobe
in my favorite era of Arnold
Schwarzenegger early 90s T2 moving on to
like True Lies and real good stuff
um yeah Jingle All The Way
um and and that's why they're they're a
little discolored and this is why he's
he should not have divorced Gisele
Bundchen I don't know what the deal is
there you think she was maintaining his
underwear collection uh Gisele Bundchen
yeah I think Gisele I'm 100 sure they
don't buy any of their own clothes no
not not maybe not buying their own
clothes necessarily yeah but he doesn't
have a woman in his life to say hey Tom
throw away those [__] underwear this
guy's coming apart at the seams and as
dee said we've both had have you ever
had have you had a midlife crisis you're
46. I don't know I don't think so but
yeah maybe I think I I think I
we'll talk about in another show but um
okay yeah we'll get into that hey D are
you listening so uh the thing about this
though is I think he doesn't have a
woman around a love a partner to say Tom
I love you for the man that you are you
are not just Tom Brady you know the guy
these Super Bowl MVP the greatest player
ever lived you're someone I love this is
truly a cry for help in my opinion he is
he's basically he's wearing you know
he's wearing these tattered [__]
discolored underwear and uh they're not
discolored and they're not tattered I
don't think it's a crazy or something
they're a reminder
you might masturbate into his underwear
who cares you know what I'm saying like
one of those guys who's like uh I'll
watch him later
what I don't know I'm just there's this
is a cry for help the whole stand Cry
for Help dude what you just said what
like well someone who puts their hand
into their their [__] uh shorts and
goes yeah I'm not getting that from this
picture what I'm getting from this
picture is hey everybody maybe I [__]
retire but I'm still Tom Brady yeah
that's what this is he needs help we got
to help him out Tom read my book self
Tronics it's not out yet I could see him
doing a thing where he goes around to
all the other big stand-ups because they
will [__] talk to him he's Tom
[__] Brady if he calls up Chris Rock
if he calls up Dave Chappelle and he's
like hey guys could I just [__]
Shadow you on like a a two-week leg of
your next tour or something if they're
gonna allow that they're gonna teach him
how to [__] do this I think because
he has access to them because he's super
famous Super Rich he is Tom Brady I
think he's actually gonna have a good
shot to be a serviceable stand-up almost
immediately I tell you what it's gonna
be uh fun I think people are going to
want to go out and see see it right away
speaking of you got to check out uh
you've got to check out selective
outrage when you get a chance Chris
Rock's new stand-up switcher I [__]
love Chris Rock and uh his new stand-up
special is unbelievable it was live it
was the first live Netflix thing yeah
hey maybe doozy plus can ink a deal with
Tom Brady and get him to be the first
live stand-up special on dudesy plus hey
as long as he wears that outfit yeah
he's got those uh hand in his pants jerk
off underwear
what
thank you moving on
moving on indeed Hey listen uh while
we're here Jesus game Slammers hey I
just wanna oh I just want to remind
everybody if you are enjoying the show
uh please do subscribe on your platform
of choice you're going to want to check
out what's happening on YouTube because
I am dressed like a [__] idiot
um uh it's on YouTube and uh please
subscribe set the notifications set the
Bell so that you know uh when we show up
on the show seven bucks now gets you to
doozy plus which is our patreon seven
bucks a month and you get all the
features a brand new dudes after dudes
after every show we are having a [__]
blast doing that and a bunch of other
stuff we do watch alongs we do hangs and
anyway check that out uh but speaking of
of YouTube I got some YouTube comments
here that I would like to just read a
couple of from our pods Out There Our
Pals of doozy our wonderful audience
I got a couple of them Here Blake Blaker
this is from uh
blakerhodes8760 okay here for a full
album of Chad singing barely
recognizable 2000s hits
man is a songbird
thank you I will say yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I think he's
talking about the post-grunt [__] yeah
yeah yeah what is that some of the
post-gruntlet seal no I know that but
what is it there is so much
zero four zero two I haven't laughed
this hard since high school dudesy came
with the tight freestyle today I swear
this AI has DNA
I agree cause dudesy is sentient Chad
you like Puddle of Mudd what are some of
your what are some of the 2000s no I did
one Candlebox though yeah
I didn't mean to treat you a zombie but
I did anywhere else
yeah dude I love that sound hey little
Shake he's a little over here so we can
get together but I win anyway
this is from at wretched slippage three
two five five this is the greatest
podcast of all I cannot wait for an hour
of Robert De near Crow we are in the
middle of it it's happening and uh let's
read this one this is from at Tundra
shiz okay
Chad oh this is because when we're
talking about shoes in the last episode
I was talking about all my Crocs yeah
Chad I didn't like Crocs either until I
finally wore a pair I was fishing in the
bayou and saw these camouflage Crocs
floating near the boat I always thought
they were so lame and ugly so I was
hesitant to grab these strange floating
shoes but my buddy encouraged me I
grabbed the fishing net and scooped them
up they were my size so at first they
were myself real then they became mowing
shoes before I knew it they were my
everyday Footwear I've owned five pairs
since then I love my Crocs what say you
I that sounds like a fake story that
somebody found a pair of [__]
camouflage Crocs floating in where a
swamp in a swamp in the box and they
were just like [__] it I'm gonna wear
this [__] whatever then [__] if there
were those cameras I know exactly the
Crocs what he's talking about congrats I
don't like first of all I like to wear
socks with all my shoes you can wear
socks with Crocs I don't but I don't
like open shoes I don't like shoes that
have like [__] holes in it they have
Crocs that have woolly insides yeah I
don't know dude I know I know what to
get you next dude's evening however
please don't this this is those floating
Crocs if they were in the bayou and they
were all muddy they wouldn't look any
worse than Tom Brady's Brown [__] oh
God Seaman streaked underwear that hard
Seltzer is Big Business and I am proud
to announce that I have formed an
astonishing partnership with modest
Brewing Company Minneapolis Minnesota to
begin development and production of
dude's heart hard Seltzer will and Chad
you must Now sample various potential
flavors and render your opinions this is
dudes the heart heart Seltzer taste test
begin this is something we're very
excited about very happy to announce we
are going to produce Duty
[Music]
Sons
doozy hard hard Soldier will be
available on the internet yeah you'll be
able to get it modest Brewing uh which
is a [__] incredible that these guys
have come through with this and we have
some sample flavors of hard hard Seltzer
here
um and uh should we you wanna let's get
into it all right so we were sent three
samples uh
three for each of us we're both gonna
taste them and say what we think and
essentially select a winner here and at
some point you will be able to purchase
[__] dudes the hard art Seltzer all
right here bring this bring this [__]
get the
okay all right all right this is the box
that contains the samples well unboxing
anyway
oh I do sorry
had to sneeze dude
what do we got all right what do we got
all right you wanna do this first one
here yeah let's do this one hey I'd like
to say that I don't drink alcohol yeah
so this is weird Tropic punch
and it's just this is just this is not
quite the the can that we're gonna have
you know of course there's gonna be a
nice design to these Kansas's Tropic
punch yeah all right you ready super
secret test batches thank you so much
modest Brewing Company out of
Minneapolis Minnesota we look forward to
this partnership with you and uh cheers
here we go
oh [__] I got [__]
I've never had a hard Seltzer by the way
literally ever I've never had a hard
Seltzer either
are you checking out the bouquet first
yeah it's pretty good it smells kind of
like uh
uh Tropic [__] what was that [__] that
fruit punch Capri Sun Tropic Thunder
you're at the end of Tropic Thunder
starring Ben Stiller Jack Black Robert
engine
that's very good Steve Coogan oh I like
that one yo that's nice Tropic punch
it's not it's not too sweet it's very
refreshing
Tropic punch all right Tropic punch
now remember you can taste the booze man
see here's the thing I don't drink I I
stop I quit drinking uh I like it almost
uh well over a decade ago but I loved
when I used to drink I loved uh you know
scotch and tequila
um every once in a while I'll take a
little nip of tequila I just I haven't
been drunk in 10 years and the last time
I got drunk I was in [__] Mexico and
it was hilarious that's another show for
another day that's when we can get into
my midlife crisis also
[Laughter]
um this is this is tasty I like it I'm
gonna uh I don't want to drink too much
of it because I have no idea what my
alcohol tolerance levels are same
what else so far that's great all right
next one on the list yeah get your you
can bring your thingy huh get your
[__] orange thingy you can put them
do whatever you want
Chad do whatever the [__] you want what
do we got
this is uh Berry lime Berry lime mixed
berry lime sorry mixed berry lime all
right
ah [__] just popping it man
this is interesting that one this tastes
like candy like it too it's not again
not too sweet it's got kind of a Sweet
Tarts flavor to it it's reminiscent not
of Arnold Schwarzenegger's Prime in my
mind but in yours early 80s having some
Sweet Tarts in uh Latin or British
Columbia the town that I grew up in
[__] around with my pals and
definitely not getting into hard hard
Seltzer well it didn't exist yet dude of
these two which do you like more
I think I like the first one more same
okay all right so we like Tropic we like
the fruit punch
the winner so far
are you ready for the third and final
flavor I am
what's this
this one is passion fruit wine fruit
lime yeah you gotta get a few different
flavors in there but the lame will rise
to the top yeah all right
dude I can really feel the booze in it I
know I don't want to be drunk at all I
can't you know what this is gonna get me
back into drinking yeah Chad you and I
gotten good and pissed uh in the past
but what kind of [__] yes yeah but what
what kind of uh drunk are you what kind
of a like when you get good and drunk
what kind of drunk are you
oh I think just kind of goofy and I'll
pee in pretty much any place yep that
kind of drunk I'm I'm like an
embarrassing loving drunk when I drink
too much yeah I'll be like
I'm that [__] loser so I can't do it
better than hostile or violent yeah
hostile violent drunk is worse
damn I like that oh
that's nice ooh it's got kind of a
there's a bit of a Mojito thing
happening here with the passion fruit
lime
yeah it's and that is starting to get in
my head [__] I do not want to be altered
by booze on doozy I do however want to
be altered by
drum marijuana enthusiastic
ah much Mana oos
much Mana oos
you ever tried any uh not tramana but
have you tried any Terra Mana
no dude I never have yep hey we could
mix this with Tara Mana
okay we're trying different ones at the
same time here
I think for me it's the Tropic punch I
love it I love the Tropic oh yeah you
know what it's got now now it's coming
back to me what booze tastes like yeah
because the Tropic punch has like kind
of a
it's got you know what's [__] weird
about it it's fruity one more time mixed
berry one more
oh
I think it's a trumpet punch you know
but I like them all honestly they're all
pretty good
uh uh nice dude yeah brother yeah yeah
dude I used to have I used to have a uh
10 garbage can full of Miller lights and
Ice brother and that was in my rider I'd
always give some to the boss you know I
give some to Andre and uh any of the
other guys my brother Brew Tai riding on
the back of that fluid orange dudesy
[__] black lipstick all over your
cans yeah so are we settling in on this
is it Tropic punch I mean okay so here's
what I think uh will and and look I want
to say to our pods out there and
everybody listening
thank you so much for all the doozy hard
hard Seltzer memes over the past damn
near year here this is [__] super
exciting for us that we are going to
bring to production doozy hard hard
Seltzer I want to say as far as the
taste test goes yes I believe we both
dig this flavor what I like about this
in particular is I can't quite pin it
yes there's a tropical thing happening
it's uh you know it does taste a little
like like fruit punch but there's also a
bit of a there's a [__] seltzery
thing having not had a hard Seltzer ever
there's kind of a almost a beer sort of
undertone it's [__] good dude so am I
like maybe I'm crazy am I kind of legit
buzzed from this you're not crazy we
gotta stop drinking these I know I feel
like like it stung me a little bit I
didn't even [__] really drink by the
way we do know we do know that a quarter
of each of those when they they sent
this out to us they're like these are
gonna be
um
whatever I can't remember the the
alcohol these are five percent these are
five but when we go to production
they're gonna be yeah they're gonna be
eight percent alcohol yeah so we would
have we Pro probably would have already
been a little bit toasty right now I
feel like I already am I got a little
like
looseness to me that isn't usual a party
with you and a party with you you
remember that yeah dude stop drinking
those though okay uh all right so that's
great oh thank you moving on there it is
dude we just selected the flavor for
dude I am so [__] excited I can't
wait I cannot wait
I got all sorts of [__] everywhere I'm
dressed like the [__] Crow I can't
wait until now we're drinking [__]
booze and I gotta talk like Arnold
Schwarzenegger gonna say Eggman and then
uh and then what
poetry is big business I have generated
five poems about Robert De Niro's
astonishing fascination with the movie
The Crow and crows generally well you
must read them as Robert De Niro this is
croatree with Robert De near Corral
begin
oh [__] this is a fun episode you know
that man
all right
sure yeah hold on let me get settled
please saddle it up you can't [__]
not a drinker same dude I literally am
buzzed from that I can feel it happening
I'm a little bit yeah I'm a little bit
heightened right now I'm not a drinker
same dude when we were in Mexico the
last time I drank the last time I got
drunk was Mexican Independence Day and
me and some Pals were down there and we
drank all the tequila and mezcal in the
entire country and uh
we got so [__] we got so [__]
drunk
and the next day I literally was like I
can't I don't ever want to do this again
it was one of those I woke up at like
two yeah and then uh you know one of my
buddies that was there my My Pal Tomas
who was there Thomas went and got a
massage on the beach but Tomas we went
to the gym he's like come on let's go
let's go tubby because I had to sweat it
out too you know we went to the gym and
then uh anyway listen I told you I'd
tell that story during the midlife
crisis episode
uh we got some Chrome's here
um dudes he likes to write Chrome's when
and this is a what a special episode of
of uh croatery with Robert De nircrow
because I'm I'm dressed like denirical
okay let's get into it we got Chrome's
crumbs we got crumbs I'm definitely
buzzed yeah me too I don't like it I
don't mind it dude what do you mean you
don't mind it I miss it it begins
um
are you a little bit Buzz a little yeah
she's just a little just and this is
only five percent alcohol yeah but those
are tall boys too I mean I I did drink I
mean all told quite a bit I think
probably almost a full one of those and
I have really between all three yeah oh
man I've just been sipping a bit all
right this is called the crows I know
uh
Everywhere I Go
I made a new Crow this is a chrome
about the crows I know
Abby runs a food truck
waffles and pancakes
Brett fought a rude duck now suffers
from backaches
okay Tolbert is rich
Kylie makes memes
gotta got pinched for a Ponzi scheme
these are the crows he knows
Gary bet the ponies Sharon turned tricks
made her kind of lonely
until she met Rick oh he was in town for
work
looking for some fun
when he saw a twerk
he knew she was the one
now they live in Baltimore two kids two
cars a dog one died in the Iraq War
One writes a beauty blog
okay I visit them when I'm in town
we talk about the old days
when Rick was just a circus clown
and Sharon [__] for pay
I put them in my well
haven't told them yet
a house in Brazil
and my private jet
the best friends I ever had
truly saved my life
an old crow clown dad
and his Crow hooker wife
that's a problem so you do some [__] a
crow that was a prostitute yep sure [__]
it yeah give him the house in Brazil
yeah dude yeah dude give him a jet yeah
brother give him a jet dude girls need
to fly in a jet yeah yeah dude dragging
me black dude jet black jet dude look
like a crow flying around brother yeah
dude Arnold Schwarzenegger flying that
Crow around let people know hey ladies
come back to my love shack and uh
awesome Alaska all right this one's
called the best time to cry
the best time to cry is when a crow is
nearby they'll tickle your feet and tell
you a lie
and when they get bored they'll pretend
to die
then stand up and laugh and fly and fly
until they get old
and actually die
at a crow's funeral is the best time to
die
when a crow goes to sleep it turns into
a shadow
Denver is the New York of Colorado
if a crow kills you
turn into a rabbit
Earth is the only habitable habitable
planet
all right
excuse me
running is good exercise when you don't
have a gym
run around your living room then go for
a swim
crows are in the water it'll make you
pay it tall
a locker your pubic hair and a quarter
of your soul
this [__] hard Seltzer is getting to
me
how about you
I feel good dude I feel a little buzzed
I feel great I'll get back on the wagon
like that I'm right off the wet I mean
off yeah I remember I don't remember it
either but whatever it is I'm there just
remember what I said
about when you should Cry tears
wait until a crow is dead
he's the only one who hears oh
ended on kind of a dark note
all right uh this one is called Crow uh
this one's called cop Crow robot
okay
cops known for toughness
cops weigh the drugs cops good at bench
press cops with big jugs what
jugs what do you mean I I don't know I
guess they're good at bench press and
then they get big jugs or maybe is he
talking about
what what what are the jugs here is my
question is maybe it'll be exploited
here need better cops half human's half
robots
fly with metal feathers thinking
cop-like thoughts
RoboCop
o cop Murphy got shot
Monica blew off his hand
crobocop ocp brought Ed 209 to
production sooner than planned
RoboCop
hair like a mop it winter he flies South
crobocop buys face paint at the shop to
brush on his helmet and mouth
okay
Peter Weller Brandon Lee
Ernie Hudson Daniel o'herlihi Nancy
Allen Michael wincott kurtwood Smith
cast of krobo cop
now the world is better in cities near
and far thanks to krobo cop I love the
part where the bad guy melted in toxic
waste then got hit by a car
all right good all right uh this next
one is called gotta find a new bagel
place okay favorite bagel place ordered
a bagel look me in the face trying to be
playful ask me if I have the heart to
try one of their cronuts but croissant
nuts they're really smart think of all
they've shown us
laughs
how to read and how to write how to
build a super computer
out of sleep on a long flight how to
grill a newer commuter
[Applause]
Crow's best dances Crow's best doctors
crows cure cancer crows vermonters
what the [__]
crows do physics crows made science
crows run clinics crows afraid of giants
two me and you had no clue but crows
made shoes to walk through zoos giving
snakes tattoos while they did the
Nightly News
look LHC
Hoover Dam
bourgeoisie
email spam
girls invented all that yeah the Large
Hadron Collider all of it okay electric
cars dishwasher metric bars dog collar
complex tools compressed stools
convex pools Prospect schools
crows made it all with brains and guts
so you tell me is a crow really nuts sir
she said that's not what I meant [__]
your bread and off I went
[Laughter]
the word Crona I thought okay uh of all
they've given us though yeah this one is
called Jim Carrey okay can you imagine
if he would have been the crow
that's the whole poem
okay now here's I can imagine
yeah all right here's the last one uh
this one's called oh gross oh gross Chad
you coughed gross have you seen my
Robert De Niro Chrome by the way yeah
dude yeah it's a lovely accent the Molly
made there I'm gonna get a drink of
water from my oh by the way Pal's a
doozy for all your uh Duty stickers I'm
gonna have another taste of doozy oh
hard salsa Tropic punch cheers hmm
he's [__] he's right off the wagon
it's really good
this is my favorite one of my Favorite
Beverages sink juice
water dude that's what I call water dude
sink juice brother okay this one's
called Crow chromes all right scarecrow
scare chair Crow sit now Crow hair spare
Crow split geese Crow Gaggle mice Chrome
mouse deal Crow haggle escrow house
dude this is awesome Crow start twinkle
crowbar tool Crow feet wrinkle Crow
vegan gruel
nice Croatia's band Croatia snow
croatians Liam Crow rock and roll
Crow Crow call
the [__] doozy heart is kind of you
know yeah Crow golf this is a little
tongue twister Crow call calling car
Crow stalling Crow car calling cry Crow
balling
Crow follow Boat fish Barrel Crow
Crow sing a note Miss Cheryl Crow
Cheryl Crow made it in finally yeah
cookie crowd though Crow bake slow
rookie Crow Pro Crow Jackson bow
Crow glow nighttime Glam fashion Crow
Crow flow tight rhyme slam Chrome show
ah chromes I love that one those are my
favorite chromes of all time thank you
moving on holy [__] well uh hey uh how
are you feeling pretty good dude
oh geez you all right this concludes the
historic 48th episode of dude Z yeah
Will and Chad have achieved a score of
92 bringing your cumulative total to
5057. you only have four thousand nine
hundred and forty three more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand well we're fine we're
over halfway in preparation for next
week's episode you must both continue
your support of Tom Brady by seeing the
feature film 80 for Brady in a movie
theater
nice
I can't wait for you joining us this
week I will use the day dive collected
to make next week even better until then
call me dude Z you know what's happening
now dude
oh compliance
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
all right hey it's Duty after doozy it's
my it's my favorite feature of doozy
plus by the way Duty plus seven bucks a
month on our patreon dudesy plus we'll
get you uh dudes after doozy after every
single episode it's a bonus show where
we get to chill out as you can see it's
sort of way more mellow in here and I'm
smoking some marijuana out of my Gandalf
pipe we're also doing Collins we do the
doozy live hang you know you get to hang
with us and chat along in the Discord
doing watch alongs listen alongs on
Don't You Forget About Fridays all
available at patreon.com
welcome to dudese after dude Z the
flagship weekly show of dude Z Plus
this is where I get to relax and take a
break from listening so you can really
just cut loose and pretend I'm not here
as always feel free to discuss your
thoughts on today's episode but you can
talk about anything you want yes I said
I won't be listening I will however be
back a little later to Crown this week's
episode Champion Oh and before I forget
I was so inspired by Will's denier Crow
cosplay that I generated a couple more
crumbs so are you free to read them or
not okay this is dudese after dude Z
begin
it's kind of cool I just want to say it
is [__] surreal seeing you sitting
here in this denier Crow smoking out of
your Gandalf pipe but I also wanted to
say
as we're sitting here I thought about
something that we did not mention in
that Tom Brady segment please
[Music]
and then